he was touring with inch clip for a
second wasn't he mm-hmm yeah they were
doing kill tony on the road yeah
for a minute high breath
uh and then i think tony moved to um
much my costume do you want to move
those
i think we're all set here
yeah oh yeah that's so cool
yeah that's very exciting
okay
recording
the perks of doing uh the one-man band
still because it's all
this is awesome i want to get a camera i
want to start recording
my sets
about to go on the rotor time
uh i will yeah it's mainly for the
podcast right now yeah um but i have
recorded my sets with it
and um
yeah because it seems like the higher
quality stuff is more shareable very
much since every open micro
is posting grainy crowd work clips to
try to go viral it's like what's going
to increase shareability and it seems
like audio and video quality yep very
much and the
i've learned i think the captions help
oh for sure like the quality of captions
what do you like like the what do you
mean like how accurate they are no like
like i was doing
um
i was sending my through this thing
called rev and it would it would caption
out maybe this sounds really weird but
i've
noticed the difference it would caption
out like
maybe a sentence at a time so it would
give you a whole sentence caption art
and i was just putting them up myself
and i'd put maybe
like smaller font
and it would just
breath so we would have the whole
sentence up there as i'm beginning the
sentence do you know me so people could
read it before i said maybe a punch line
and then i i hired lysandra to uh i've
had her caption some of my stuff and
this is what she does she's a she's a
social media
she's like a content creator who
lisandra vasque vasquez oh yeah who does
hot comics yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and uh
so and i've if you've ever like watched
other some other um
captioned content you'll notice they put
like
one to three maybe five words max and
they literally type in the word as it
said
and it like so you're not ruining the
punchline before it before you say it
it's weird but you do it all at once
you're saying
so like like the words come up as you're
saying them so it's not like a whole
sentence is up there and you could read
the punchline before it's developed oh
you're saying you do the opposite where
you do just the word at a time yeah oh i
thought you were saying you did the
whole thing at a time some people read i
was doing it before and those were fine
like they were getting fine traction but
the sense i've i've had her caption them
and they they have like the one word at
a time
those are the ones that haven't popped
off oh snap oh that's good to know yeah
because those are all the like they say
like the
the tiny hinges open bigger doors yeah
so it's like those are the little
differences that make the big difference
and i i also i don't know if this makes
a huge difference but she's so good at
it that she'll add
her captions kind of
hopefully he'll cheer up he likes to
throw his bone on the ground mister yeah
no you're good but he like
she'll like it's almost like the
captions are making their own joke jokes
sometimes like have you ever noticed how
some captions like if you emphasize a
word she'll take the word and then
she'll italicize the word yeah yeah yeah
yeah like she'll the way she'll like
arrange a word like what i don't know if
you see that dnf bit of mine but like
she went like dnf and she
changed the colors and did a dude it
vertical
she animates the caption yeah i've seen
like i saw the clip they posted
of when you were on their podcast and it
was like a florida quote and she like
animated florida and like made it it's
almost like if you watch it without
sound it's still entertaining yes yeah
and like some of my
the don't tell clip i had i i was i did
some sound effects and so they they had
my words down normal caption but they
were doing like the almost like a comic
strip would be like f or pow or
something like that yeah yeah they had
them up like diagonal on the side and it
i don't know i don't know if it makes a
huge difference but i feel like it does
especially now is like every time you
get on social media
like every comedian is posting stuff so
it's like all right how can i separate
myself from just everyone posting them
standing and saying things and i think
all those little things are going to
make a difference now more than ever
just because everyone figured out oh i
post my clips and maybe i'll go viral so
now it's like what else can you do
besides you know besides being funny
yeah you know it's like what can you do
to stand out when people are just
sitting here doing this yeah it's almost
like yeah i i i think about it i don't
know maybe i'm thinking about it too
much but you you it even helps to sell a
bit like i saw one how somebody
it you know it was captions it was like
word word word and then they they had
kind of it was like they were going on a
rant and they were adding and adding so
rapidly to this like tactic tag
so the captions
just started to
they just added them around their face
oh yeah and it was like you know until
it was like a whole thing around their
face
and it just kind of you know it like
added to the the the like the rant or
whatever yeah yeah i was literally just
talking about that we're talking before
this about my interview with jeremiah
watkins
and how
he basically his he's creating so much
content and all of it is like he does
several podcasts but none of the stuff
he shares is just like
him standing or him sitting and talking
there's effects there's like zooms
there's there's so many different bells
and whistles and i think you pointing
that out even just how you do the
captions mix
that really yeah that really connects
with me because i'm
i'm someone who's like i see people
doing something and i'm like all right
but what's another way you know i don't
i try to catch the next wave instead of
riding the current one so i'm always
looking for like what's next and then so
that could be what's next is you posting
a bunch of clips but how you can do it
in an entertaining way even without
sound yeah it is a whole different i
mean i i've like learned a little bit
about
how to caption and like i'm trying to
teach myself adobe premiere but it's
like a whole new
i mean if it's honestly like if you just
could hire somebody
if you can like
if you can honestly because basically
everything i do right now is still me i
work with an editor some but i'll still
do a lot of my own editing and stuff and
like literally if you
if you can't outsource it like you even
bring it up lisandra yeah
i'm like i want to reach out to her
after this because like i i'm at a point
now it's worth the investment yes to
just
you give someone who's good at that and
then you focus on what you're good at
exactly because it is so much work dude
it adds up yeah that's the that's i
think the next level what i'm
experiencing now like i'm starting to
talk to people and i'm realizing okay
that's how you level up is when you
start to build a team in any sense
and i'm i'm
the kind of person that's like i would
rather
so now i i've kind of gone a little bit
viral and i'm starting to make something
alright
let's go
like easy teensy tiny bit um for my
reels on instagram yeah yeah whatever
that money is i just
use it to pay to like edit more videos
just to reinvest
yeah that's great because what i mean i
might as well do that instead of what
buying
another pair of jeans or something you
know
but like i'm realizing the the more you
work on
if you can like if you build up to a
point that you can have a team it's
worth the investment to pay other people
to focus on stuff so that you can focus
on
writing or your art or whatever else
you're creating yeah i mean even this
podcast like i did all the audio for a
long time and i can do it but now i just
send it because i love helping comics
and i like you know comics helping
comics is like what this whole show's
about so
i now just send it to another comedian
who's also an
audio engineer so i'm like supporting
his business while also supporting like
the greater good of comedy while also
saying yes i could do this but i could
literally just send the files to him and
then it comes back completely done yeah
and in that time i would have spent
doing what i know what to do
just i could be doing other more
productive things yeah you could create
a you could do another podcast you could
write
you know there's other stuff yeah i
think it's
it's like a time management thing too
yeah
you're getting the heat so it's you're
you're you're at that you're doing it
you did it what is it what does it feel
like i what does it feel like because
i've seen you since you started yeah and
then it's so cool like
a lot of us comedians are playing almost
like roulette online of like maybe this
one go viral maybe with this one and
then you're like oh my gosh i know her
and it worked and now they're like what
does it feel like i can't i was telling
my friend
yesterday
uh driving i was driving to to nashville
zanies and i i got this unbelievable
call
and i hung up with her and i called my
friend and i was like i'm
you go you grind for so long for so many
years and
you you're so used to being really
excited about something and it not
happening or it doesn't happen the way
you were really hoping it would happen
that i it's i'm like
skeptical like it doesn't feel real
because you're like no no no i'm i
should be disappointed like i should be
i didn't get it like i'm not this
feeling doesn't it doesn't feel it
almost feels
like i'm about to be tricked
because you're so because i've been so
used to you know like everything
is underwhelming yeah um and i do i
still i i still feel like this is all
gonna end in a in a very hot second and
you're gonna be back to
i mean i'm still i'm always gonna grind
i'm always gonna work but
right now it's starting to it's a weird
moment where like
all of a sudden people are like reaching
out to you and being like no i want to
do this for you i see you with this
potential i want to do this for you and
all of a sudden the first time in your
mom your life you're you're not doing
everything you don't have to do
everything yeah
i don't know it's i i'm
i'm i feel like i'm looking behind me at
all times being like okay when when is
asher kutcher going to come out and be
like this is a prank
you thought you thought that was gonna
happen to you come on no we were kidding
go back to nanning sit down yeah like
you're you're opening up for like david
spade and you're like is he really going
to show up to the show is this really
happening
when i was when i flew to that gig and
like walked into the hotel i fully
expected to walk up to the front desk
and be like a hotel room for catherine
blandford and they were just going to
laugh and be like no
no no no no
yeah genuinely it's i don't i don't know
i think because for after years and
years and years of of
nothing happening just doing yeah just
bombing in cafeterias correct
you know
yeah you're doing it now and let me just
last night you drove back from nashville
this morning like 5 00 a.m to be back
here in georgia like it
the grind never stops and that's what
people don't i think understand is like
you're go you went viral but it's like
yeah you were still like driving all
night you're still like you're still a
working grinding comedian oh i'll never
stop i mean now it's to the point where
like i wanna i i i'm so excited to even
go to the next level i can't wait to get
there i'm i'm a bit uh addicted to this
of course oh yeah we all are yeah yeah
yeah and now you see like oh i i now i i
have people coming at me and being
wanting to help me i can't now let's go
let's go after this let's go after this
this is possible now
you know just
you don't have to you have to spill the
beans because i don't i don't like
saying anything like
before like i don't like saying things
until after it's happened you know so i
don't i don't like to because i've had
several things in my career that i'm
like oh my gosh this is it and then it
that doesn't come out or i get edited
out or whatever so i don't like to say
anything but it's like
like um i'm trying to think of an
example what did happen all right the
david spade thing yeah that's something
you may be here and you're like all
right is this really gonna happen and
then it does so how did how did that
come to be
uh
weird funny story so uh
andrew stanley yes
uh
lana baseball amazing comic
he has been opening for him i think he
opened from atlanta and they loved him
and so he was i i'm sure he's been in
maybe almost 10 cities with him now um
he had to cancel a gig here locally to
open for david spade and so they asked
me to fill andrew stanley's spot at it
it was a high school graduation like a
ju like a community i don't know how to
say a jewish
like kids who all grew up in the same
like jewish community right and like
four of them were graduating so they're
all their parents through this little
community graduation party for them and
they're like wouldn't it be great if we
had stand-up comedians
they hired so it was originally supposed
to be andrew and then nick murphy i took
andrew's spot
uh and we go out there and it's just
like
a plethora of high school kids
and maybe even younger sitting on these
blankets their parents they're they were
all chatting and eating cookies and they
made them stop and go over to these
blankets and sit down there and listen
to these stand-up comedians
joel
this is when my my videos had started
popping off and i was like okay feeling
yourself even better than i really
thought i was
america is seeing me
i go up there and i mean i'm giving them
the hits like i'm trying not a peep
they're they're they're 13 years old
they're trying to hang out at a party
and then they're like the stranger yes
yes
what i was to them i might as well be
their chemistry teacher
monday morning you know trying to
lecture them they were like this we hate
this we have to do this every day at
school we don't want to do this again
uh and it was just it was hell i mean
but i don't know if you've ever
like college is different but anything
younger than college they're not they
don't know what stand-up is they don't
know
to sit there and enjoy one person
talking on a mic i'm like i was i almost
started dancing at the end
it was rough i had texted andrew and i
was like hey um you just missed the gig
of a lifetime
he texted me yeah he texts me back a
picture of him on stage at this theater
show for david spade and he goes but
actually
we were at dinner afterwards and spades
showed me his phone and goes do you know
who this chick is and it was my don't
tell comedy clip
and he goes and andrew was like yes my
friend catherine was like oh she's funny
uh and turns out they had a date in
jacksonville that andrew couldn't do
because he was going to a wedding with
his fiancee and uh so they were like
would you want to ask your friend
catherine
what that's how it happened so i i mean
it was a little bit of a don't tell clip
it was a little bit of just
being having a friend
there at the right time that they could
that was an easy contact for them to be
like oh well you know somebody
the friend that booked you
the bad gig right but then the comedy's
like that though yeah it it gives and
takes like there's a low but there's a
high like yeah so it that is funny
you're doing this horrible gig
booked by your friend i mean it pays you
know those those pegs yeah those gigs
pay so you you just you kind of check
the box on that kind of stuff
but
that's so funny about comedy is it's
like oh this terrible gig and then you
call your friend and you're like thanks
for this terrible gig and he's like
actually i have maybe the best gig of
your career so far if you would like
like it's so funny how comedy balances
out like that yeah i think that's also
why
right now it stuff feels so exciting
there there's that voice in the back of
my head going but remember
like you're gonna be burnt soon
comedy humbles you like that yeah it's
you you just know that it's always an up
and down which i think is why um it's so
addicting
yeah you're like chasing that high yeah
like
that one show yeah yeah what was it like
working with mr spade i
i'll sing his praises to the end of time
he was
the coolest most personable
silliest goofiest guy
you like we got to go to dinner before
and him and bobby miyamoto
he travels with him a lot super super
nice super friendly guy super funny um
we just got to chill at dinner and like
we were all chatting and laughing
they're just they're down to earth
guys like we were all telling stories
laughing and you you then you forget you
that
you know you're with somebody famous
until you get in a black car and you
drive around the theater and there's
thousands of people wrapped around the
building and then
they have to have security open up the
car and you he gets out and then you get
up behind him and everyone's like
david and you're and you're behind him
like thank you i'm wearing target
uh you know but it was it was so
it's so it's weird because you're in the
car before just cracking you i felt like
i was in the green room with my friends
at a show yeah um but you're not used to
having that reaction from fans at the
same time so it was really cool
um
we got into the theater and like we're
just we just chilled and cut up and
laughed and we're goofy the entire time
he's he's
a phenomenal dude great i've worked with
i've done i've opened for a lot of
people variety of like top-notchers now
uh and some of them aren't always
as friendly and i don't think you yes
sorry somebody wants to be part of this
mister yeah he needed some attention
uh you're good
i don't think i don't say everybody has
to be the most friendly because you know
you're working with people all the time
but i thought he was about to drop it on
my head
would he do that would he like
if he if he's desperate enough
we didn't see a bone flies
he's like his mom we love attention so
we'll do it any way we can
um yeah but he's he's definitely
the friendliest
mr it's not about you right now
this is her this is her big
oh this is this is the baby in our house
so no
he doesn't he doesn't know anything that
that unless it's all about him no
worries at all yeah he's cutie thank you
he's from the streets he's a mix of
everything we're talking about you
working with david spade and he's like
this is my show exactly my time yeah and
he'll drop a huge bone down the steps
just dent our steps
no worries at all
um
yeah so i and i always
i've said this
from the beginning i was even texting
one of my friends uh david perdue yes
when i did my first open mic i remember
he messaged me afterwards and he was
like hey i just i saw you the mic you
look like you were having fun on stage
that's half the battle keep at it and
i've kept that in the back of my head to
remember would be like okay you know
there's people that that that might not
be the best starting out but don't write
them off mm-hmm because they could they
could build themselves up and be
somebody someday of course that's why
you always want to be nice to people too
yes i mean you want to be nice people in
general of course but like but for your
personal gain is what i'm telling you of
course yeah as a strategic ploy yes you
never know what comic you saw
bombing at an open mic is going to end
up booking like the top shows in the
southeast or whatever right you know so
always always be nice
uh yeah is he making you nervous next to
your camera
he's good though he knows how to like
walk right around it is the famous last
words there
how long have you been doing comedy
seven years seven years yep
and you started in atlanta started
atlanta i took a class uh at the improv
and then it closed six months later nice
not that i had anything to do with it
uh i probably did like i wasn't like
super hardcore until about two years in
oh like doing it like nightly yeah okay
cool yeah is that
no that's totally fine i doubt that'll
even pick up on here over here okay good
yeah we're good
yeah yeah so i probably i think like two
years in is is when i like
really went hardcore in
uh
and i i i had a job i had a really cool
job i was working like event management
but in the venues oh yeah and i was i
used to work for orlando magic and i
came back up here for a smaller venue
and then i started comedy and then i was
offered the dallas cowboys job like at
their stadium oh my gosh we need you
down there in two weeks um this is when
beyonce and jay-z were
their their first tour their first
stadium tour on the run and they were
you know you would be running that
and i
was like actually i'm gonna quit i want
to do stand up
[Music]
so this is why it has to work for me
because i i i gave up a lot literally
the thing you had your college degree
for
is like all right you're about to be in
like one of the nicest nfl stadiums
beyonce jay-z you're like no i want to
do open mics and coffee shops yes the
the most mega of everything the most
mega stars the most mega
concert the most mega venue and i was
20
22 23 maybe at the time
so young i worked my works
weirdly up very quickly
i hold on let me grab that from him but
yeah um
i don't know i just but also you you
realize though it sounds amazing but
like i was doing nights and weekends and
working during the day too and it's like
if you there's no point in grinding on
something that you hate doing that and i
would do it i would and i'm a workaholic
but i have to like it i want to i want
to work i want to be a workaholic on
something i love so what does that work
look like for you now is are you wait
are you are you still in you're still a
nanny i'm still naming this time yeah i
mean it's more it's a lot it's part time
now yeah you're like you're easing into
full-time stand up so like what what is
what does the work look like for you as
like a comedian now kind of what are all
the different things you're working on
how do you like approach your days like
yeah what's the work of comedy for you
yeah so i i would say i wish i could say
i wake up and write every
morning it doesn't always happen maybe i
write i love to i like to start
journaling i do the morning pages yeah i
do that more than anything yeah yeah
three pages non-stop
uh but usually what the mornings consist
of because i have my mornings free for
myself um i wake up walk camp workout
have to work out for my mental
state of mind and then i'll it's usually
dedicated to podcasting
lace larabee and i have our our chitties
podcast we do our interviews in the
morning and then we do a catch-up
episode every other week and then so
it's either i'm recording or editing a
clip for the podcast or editing a clip
for
social media
and then if i can get writing in
i will but usually i'll go i'll go nanny
and then i'll get i'll go to like a
coffee shop i'll pack my bag so i can't
so i don't come home like force myself
yeah so like but so i'll have like a
weird hour and a half in between working
and going to a show
i've already packed my bag there's no
point in coming back home
so i have to go to a coffee shop and i
sit down and i write
what are you are you like seeking out
like bookings or anything on that end or
like the business side of it
yeah that's uh that's what i that's the
cool part is what i was i guess alluding
to who knows i don't i don't want to
speak on it too soon but of course i
have
lately been getting
contacted a lot more about bookings and
it's
uh
it's been a i'm like i don't
i don't know what my rate is you know i
don't know what to tell them do i do i
ask for transportation and everything um
so
you learn at some point like oh this is
how comics do it they have people they
have they have agents this is this is
really cool
um so
uh i've been talking with
a few
maybe a few people like agents you're
talking about yeah who will help me out
eventually with that but before it was
always
i mean that like
as far as like sending out emails and
everything i maybe six months ago did
have somebody a friend who um
was like i'd love to be your unofficial
booker um
which was like kind of a handshake deal
you know we'll do this as long as it
works for you and
i was like okay here's my email template
here's who this is the kind of venues
i'm interested in working on and since
then she's been like i've that's another
automated
system where she's like all right so she
just sends out emails and then if i book
something she gets 10 of it but
my day is packed already and i have to
go back to nanny and everything and that
that like set taking care of emails is
was a hard thing for me to do so i'm
saying like that was another thing that
was worth me
you know maybe spending a little bit
extra on yeah um but to
have somebody else take care of it for
me
yeah and now like this this next level
so like you go viral and then now like
agents started reaching out to you is
that kind of the
progression
for me i i guess i guess that's what
happens i mean yeah i'm also learning
what agents do what and what and who's
worth what like yeah i mean you know a
lot of people in comedy so it is worth
being like if you can vet these people
reaching out to with anyone like that
maybe knows because there's a lot of
people in the game who are like
may have like mystique or whatever but
then they end up not really doing
anything and right like so
yeah i mean i've just heard i've been
independent my whole time but i've
definitely heard stories of like
people
signing their
like opportunities away to people they
don't even know so it's yeah i'm just
exciting time for you though i'm excited
for you yeah it's exciting but i'm i'm
also
learning like i'm learning very in real
time
uh
how to vet people the questions to ask
legitimate questions
[Laughter]
i mean he's usually so chill oh it's all
good it's like they sense the moment
um that they need to be chill but
literally the one with i do with
jeremiah oh now now mister's doing it
but the one i do with jeremiah the dog
kept bringing chewie toys and kept
jumping in our laps and like it was
literally the entire interview so
it's all good when i do podcasts
upstairs he just lays at my feet he's
chilling
but he know he knows this is hot breath
he wants his hot breath moment he does
[Laughter]
there was there's doggy melatonin in
that bone and you would think it's doggy
cocaine i thought it would be doggy
adderall yeah make you nostalgic of your
usc days buddy
i mean to kick that underneath there
that might be good
you go chill out uh yeah but it's a it's
a lot of like learning also what what's
worth it right now
what's worth it to sign for and what's
not
um
so i i'm probably gonna make a lot of
mistakes but it's like it's like
anything else you just got to keep doing
it figure it out yeah that's what i've
heard you say and talk about stand-up
though is just like the failure aspect
of it is like you love the failure
because that's those are like your best
lessons too
yeah i also i mean
i e this is my same approach to writing
even when i
start a bit like i i like to write
i'm like i'm gonna say every aspect of
it that i can on stage even if it's not
i go i love i still love an open mic
can't go to my experience oh you're so
free yeah yeah yeah people like oh i was
so pumped when i i didn't have to go to
open mics anymore i don't need open mics
i'm like i will forever
hit up an open mic because i know the
beginning of my i don't i guess it's my
mental i don't i i don't need it i don't
i just need to god
dude
this is so good
you know what you're doing
you're being a little brat
you know
you need to be quiet here
um
but i it was i just i love to like
like just
throw just just talk free about
something and like throw out every
aspect of of a premise and everything
and i know 75 80 of it is gonna bomb and
or just not get anything
but i have to i have to figure that out
like lifetime yeah so i i have to fail
to get something good
so like when you're developing we could
we could say salt daddy because that's
that's like the name of your album it's
like a big story
that you tell that i feel like i've been
able to see like the progression of that
story as well seeing you out at so many
shows so it's
how
how did you develop that story from like
oh my gosh we're twerking on a pontoon
boat and now this is like the name of my
album and it's like a premier bit like
how did you develop that into such like
a tight story i that also that bit was
it probably
was
it took years to really
fine-tune it and even i thought i had it
to a certain point and then i decided i
was when i wanted to put it on the album
the end wasn't it never really hit as
hard as i wanted it to and so probably
i'd probably do been doing it a certain
way for a year maybe and then added this
bit maybe three months before the album
the end of the bit three months before i
recorded the album and it has hit so
much harder since then so i think
i i don't i don't i
i think i started that bit when i was
much i was a newer comic
and the beginning when i was really
throwing it out there there was parts of
that story that i don't even include
anymore or i've changed a little bit to
make it more
comedic but not as truthful yeah what
are you gonna do yeah yeah um but i had
to figure out
what aspects of the story were funny and
what to like lean in on and expand more
on and i had to say other parts of the
story
and multiple times to be like all right
this is this is a dead part i don't need
to i need to chop this off
but it it probably probably changed and
morphed for maybe three years maybe four
years have i been doing that bit did you
write it out longhand first or like
riffing on stage to develop it
and adding all these little comedic like
flares yeah you referenced i i'll write
it out i'll journal it right out the bit
and then
i'll i'll say it on stage and then i
listen to it and i go okay well there's
a pop there's a pop here's a super low
here's a super lull and i'll go let's
add tags into that lull or let's figure
out a different direction
and then i'll go back and i'll and then
i'll try it again but i i like to be
loose on stage because i do get a lot
from just riffing and being silly so i
there's a weird thing about i don't like
i i love to keep doing a bit
even after i feel like it's fine-tuned
because like even after like three
months of doing it you'll have a riff
that that'll be like that'll make it so
much better
um if we don't do that
and then you just record your sets to
like remember
like what you said and then you start to
refine it that way basically i listen to
recorded sets a lot
that's something i feel like everyone
records their sets but to actually go
back and listen to them it's almost like
torture yeah i mean
i don't listen to all of them sometimes
i'll be like i'll just know but okay
i did the bit how i usually do it
there's nothing i'm gonna gain from
listening to this
i'll delete it but if i was really loose
it was a silly show i rift a lot i'll
listen to it or especially if it's a new
bit and i'm
developing it the i always go back and
listen to those but i always record my
shows just in case
and then if i'm like okay that was
pretty standard i don't want it i didn't
try anything too crazy or too new i'll
just delete it yeah i always have the
intention of i'm listening to all of
them and then yeah yeah i mean at some
point you know like you know the bit you
know the sets you can listen to and then
you know unless you're trying out
something super new yeah or working
towards something because that that
definitely helped me when i did when i
did my special was it's like
having something to work towards like
you said you didn't find the ending of
the story until like almost you're about
to record your album yeah so it's like
having something you're working towards
really helps the creative process of
like well
the motivation isn't just i'm grinding
i'm trying to figure this out but it's
like i have to do it for this moment so
even if like a comedian's metric is i
have this big this big showcase or this
big paid gig i want to be ready for it's
like having these milestones to work
towards really kind of create that
pressure that makes diamonds yeah
i would say the the album
had changed a lot for me
as far as my my
vision and my my discipline
because i
i it was the first time that i really
had a deadline for something it wasn't
like okay this is just a show right
i i'll do it i'll perform it for this
person in the room it's done i was like
no this is going out to everything
everyone and it put into perspective of
right
to create a
a product that you're going to put out
so now everything i'm writing like i'm
like i want a new hour
everything i write i'm putting i'm i'm
i'm like okay this is a bit but
is it going into my story of this hour
where am i going to put it in this hour
what what's kind of is there a theme
going along here
um
but i i think like i don't even love my
album right now
you don't love your album
i mean i recorded it seven months ago
and i'm gonna be honest
i feel like i've grown a lot as a comic
with even in those seven months and some
of those bits i i was i've still done
and i've fine-tuned them even more and
i've learned so much even in those seven
months that i listen to it i'm like man
there's
a thousand things i would have done
differently or fixed or chopped or
whatever
but i'm so grateful because ever since
doing the album i've it's it's
streamlined
being like okay let's just stop like
doing things and just waiting in the
void for stuff write for
make something like create something
with it go put something out yeah so now
it's like i'm i'm much more disciplined
and you're parlaying it aren't you doing
like working on like a horse
girl like like show for a web or
something aren't you working on a horse
girl's shirt capacity yeah uh yeah
there's a
um you don't have to give away too much
you don't want okay okay but it's like
you're parlaying something from your
stand up yeah and like all right how
else can i repurpose this from like a
branding and just content standpoint
like what else can i do with i have this
bit about a topic what else can i do
with it correct yeah yeah um yeah and
it's like i love every dope thing i
bring up you're doing you're like
i don't know
i mean our girls but i i'm with you like
i don't i don't say anything until after
something's happened like i'm i'm at
that point so yeah
this one i could say i mean it's just i
i just want to do i i love the horse
girl idea it's so fun for me i've i've
i've been i still like doing the bid on
stage because
i now have turned it into such a crowd
work situation because there's always
some horse girls with some wild stories
that i've and i grew up in kentucky so
i've now i just i'm i'm a horse girl but
i only only in the context of
the lisa frank unicorns and you know
like watching uh
like um
uh
black beauty on you know and wild hearts
can't be broken
yes exactly i remember that so like now
i'm like okay no i'm gonna go
find out what real horse girls are and
like actually learn and like there's so
i have an idea to go like it's like it's
like a show you're like going and
visiting horse girls yeah like to a barn
i'm going back and you know i have some
some racehorse connections back in
kentucky and and and like going to every
aspect of actual horse girls oh my i was
picturing like sketches but the fact
it's like it's like that's awesome yeah
no it's just me
um
learning in real time what actual horse
girls go through
you're like guy like guy fieri yeah
doing diners drive-ins and dives but
it's you visiting horse girls correct
yes wow yeah there's a lot of money
there too maybe you could book some gigs
off of that too i know i'm hoping to so
i'm like writing more horse girl stuff
but truly i think the best part is is
that i genuinely don't actually know
anything about horses
it's just like the fantasy it was is
what i was so obsessed with
but you were about that life i mean
weren't you one of these people at
kentucky derby running on the porta
potties and stuff too like you were you
were d you were about that life though
yeah i mean
i mean there was nothing about that that
had anything to do with actual horses
that was me partying in the infield at
dirty
doing my own porta potty race up top uh
but
yeah i've i've sent like i've kind of
been
i mean you you grew up in louisville
home of the kentucky derby churchill
downs like you're you know you're you
you
you're ingrained in it a bit like i
would be going to the track on you know
you go there for father's day and easter
sunday and it's fun to walk around the
back where the horses are the barns
where they're getting baths and and
training and i i'm
i like i'm obsessed with it but i
i know that there's a whole industry
there's a whole world that exists
that
um
i would like just i'm so interested in
just diving more into it that's great
though it's something you're naturally
interested in yes it's not something you
feel obligated to do that oh maybe i can
capitalize on this but it's something
you're naturally interested in so the
work is actually fun yeah yeah very much
so yeah i feel like a lot of times we're
as comics we chase
something because we see it working for
someone else i mean like it what really
struck me is like the social media thing
is like
i know a comic who's doing very well
on social media with like the
side-by-side reaction videos where like
every comic now is like there's a video
and then they're like reacting to it
yeah and it's like a format it's like a
format that works and i saw him at a
show recently and he was
complaining about like he hates
recording them and he's like he sits in
his car and does them all at once and
that just hit me that's like oh this
guy's like going viral doing this thing
that he hates yeah it's like so what's
it's really finding what you love to do
and then figuring out the overlap of
like what actually gets hits on social
media and what you enjoy to do and
finding that overlap can take you know a
lot of failure and repetition to find
but i think it's it's uh it it's more
sustainable
for sure and you can when you watch
somebody who is
genuinely interested in what they're
talking about and doing it's it's fun to
watch yep exactly yeah yeah it's like we
talk about the finding a differentiator
and like the content you create it's
like you having fun like does translate
through the screen it actually
translates through the phone if you're
phoning it in versus you're actually
enjoying and passing about what you're
talking about yeah so it makes a big
difference very much
so i have to ask you this as we land
this plane here because this is
something like as comedians like you're
you're doing it like
because i'm 12 years into comedy so it's
like i i've seen
when i first started
it was just like do open mics yeah
all the time and then like maybe a
gatekeeper will
do this or that for you but it's like to
see the evolution of social media now
and then to see someone like you
started open mics now you're going viral
now you're like
you're like having this career off of
this it's like what is
what does it feel like when you're
posting a bunch of stuff
and then one works like are you just
like living on your phone now just like
refreshing just like i am so cool i am
so cool honestly
yes and i hate it i hate it i mean my
boyfriend my boyfriend's like hi
hey
what's up you want you have some dinner
and you're just like i'm awesome i'm off
yeah i'm like dm me a picture of dinner
you know
they can't be bothered um
and it i i honestly like i know i'm so
conscious of of being like do you got
because it also
it also kind of it i'm it makes you a
little bit
um i'm like dude not the world is not
about me i've got to move on from from
my dms and my comments like there's news
there's stuff happening outside the
world there's a sunshine out here so
it's really exciting for a second but
then i'm kind of getting more used to
just being like okay i'm getting a lot
of
i got a lot of hits all the time and
it's not as exciting and i'm happy about
it because i'm like okay i can i can put
my phone down and go
out into the world again um but it is
it's
it's really exciting you do have this
fear
there's you know
as soon as you get something it's like
there's just new pressures and and fears
you feel like okay i've got to
capitalize on it i got this tiny window
to capitalize and i've got to do
everything right and perfect to really
solidify and people reaching out to you
like let me tell you what you got to do
on youtube now and instagram and dinner
this this and you're
you're kind of listening to this advice
back and forth and then but then at some
point you have to just stop and be like
okay
enjoy it
don't
maybe maybe it's just for a month maybe
it's just for two days
it'll it might happen again but like you
can't put this pressure on yourself that
that like this is this you have a tiny
window of opportunity to capitalize on
it and or or else the world's gonna end
or even yeah post things like i've had a
few like nothing like what you've had
hit but like i've had a few things like
hit i mean even something getting 10 000
views you're like oh my gosh all right
what do i post next it's it better be
even better than this and if it gets 10
views instead of 10 000 then i'm
quitting comedy yeah the next post is so
scary
you're like i messed up i screwed up i
right after one of my clips went viral i
posted this
clip from my podcast and the the minute
clip had kind of an explanation before
we went into this joke part and my
friend was like why don't you just put
the joke part up just make it really
short they like really short and i was
like that's a good idea and i posted it
but i guess without the explanation
before it was so confusing and people
were just like slamming the
what is this like they were
you're and they were getting offended
like whatever it was it was just so
silly and i was like what have i done i
screwed up everything
i've lost it all like everything i
worked for it was right in my hands and
i threw it away
and it's it's an insane thing what
social media will do to your brain like
especially the more you you do go viral
the more you're you get thirsty for that
like
triumph again and so
so you'll go through these like crazy
circus
in your head and so and eventually you
have to be like okay
this is this will drive you insane if
you let it and so you have to like after
a while after the excitement kind of
calms down it feels good to just put
your phone away and be like okay there
is a world outside
you know there's wars going on there's
other [ __ ] that matters besides your
your stupid podcast clip you just posted
that didn't do well you know and you
have to like you have to remember to
like
put it aside and live in the real time
for a second
it's a wild
like industry we're in and time because
it's changing rapidly and social media
has so much to do with it right now and
it just like how long ago did you go
viral like it recently so recent yeah
within a month but days feel so long now
you know at the top of the mountain you
know heavy is the crown i guess
[Music]
oh and i'm i am a monster now too you
know when nikki glazer follows you
you're like you can't yes you know
exactly um
my crown just tipped a second uh
yeah no it probably has been i think a
month maybe maybe like two months since
the don't tell clips have come out
um but yeah it's been it's been a lot
really fast
i i i don't know like i don't know how
people who are
mega ultra famous i kind of get how
we even with the two months of my clips
going semi-viral i'm like oh i get miley
cyrus now i mean it's like yeah when you
you see someone like uh like justin
bieber they're like i can't believe he
was racing lamborghinis in his
neighborhood when he was 17. it's like
imagine
the amount of power
on your 17 year old brain
it's like i mean yeah when i was 17 it
was like you know oh i won bloody
knuckles today you know but if you're
like
i won paper football but like when you
go viral like i i'm sure you feel like
like invincible and it's also the people
that just inflating you inflating your
reality yeah
and then yeah and so i mean luckily
i mean i'm talking like i'm a hot shot
i'm not but we're talking about the
reality of like this moment like so many
comics are chasing now yeah but it's
it's good like i'm still a nanny so you
know still monday morning i go back and
then we're up at 5 a.m today driving
back from nashville correct correct
driving yourself
somebody later somebody like kiki will
you wipe me and i have to be like okay
but never you know it could still it's
it's nice to be brought back back down
to like reality also because you have to
realize
it
it is so fleeting and you're like okay
well then
get back to work like this whole i love
this horse girl
i guess webs i don't know what i'm going
to call it yet thing but are you doing
it yourself like are you recording
yourself or you're like doing it
i've i'm
i i'm talking to lasandra again she's
we're going to record it together she's
going to be like my my producer but
she's going to be involved in the clips
as well so now we're reaching out and
and scheduling
uh real horse girls to go meet up with
and just but it's like okay get back to
work if you this yeah this is fun this
was cool but you know you put these
clips online people want to come see you
now they don't want to see all the same
material that you just put online get
back to writing girlfriend go back to
mike's work this material go
find other content to put online like
it's just
it's also reminding that like okay
they're over this clip and if you want
another one you've got to work hard to
get
something else to go viral
so yeah so what what's what's next what
are you like working on because that is
something you referenced earlier over
like so many people giving you like tips
and ideas of what you should do and
things like that and what i've learned
is one
look at the source like whenever even
like at open mics sometimes comics will
come up to you and be like oh have you
thought of this or that and it's like
look at that comment and be like are
they doing what i would aspire to do are
they at open mics doing new things are
they doing cool creative outlets are
they going to open mics getting drunk
doing the same thing over just talking
to you to make themselves feel better
same thing
in the world in the industry in general
is there's people that want to
give advice just to feel important
correct but you want to take the source
for context like do i want to listen to
that i appreciate them taking the time
but like is that someone i would aspire
to be like or work with or whatnot and i
think what what's helped me make
decisions
is like knowing what i want you know all
right where do i want to be in five
years or what not what excites me what
do i want to be working on so like for
you you you you have this moment
and the good thing you're funny the good
thing is you popped and you're funny and
you're talented and you're gonna be able
to back it up and build a career off of
this and not just be like a bottle
rocket but like for you like what is it
what what do you
you're funny and you're talented so what
do you want to do with that now like
what do you see with your career yeah i
mean i think now it's about uh
i mean i guess
it's about building a team so you can
elevate to the next level so now i'm i'm
getting to the point where i can you
know like talk about talk to
representation and building and um a
couple things is like okay i want i want
an hour i want to shoot an hour
and this sounds cocky but i'm like i'm
done i'm done playing small like i want
to be i want to have something on tv in
two years
so uh i'm like okay get to writing
have put
build a team together to get on the road
and like be able to to be a road comic
working this new hour
you know and and so that's one um like i
said i want to be on tv i want to have
my stand up on tv
very soon so talking to the right people
putting a game plan together for that
then again like continuing okay you've
built an online audience how do you keep
that up in a sustainable way it's it's
putting the horse girl stuff together or
like you know continuing to edit clips
so it's like
i've now i've i've been like okay what i
want to do in a year what i want to do
in two years what i'd want to do in five
years i've
i have that mapped out i know it now and
now it's like building the team and
building the the content to get there
too oh yes well anything i can do to
help or anything hot breath can do to
help you know
we're all about comics helping comics
here and to get to do this on the day
your debut album drops i'm uh i'm
honored that you drove back from
nashville at 5 00 a.m
this is i'm telling you i'll always do
this like
i want to i just i want to have my whole
day packed yeah me too with just
exciting stuff yeah
or work i i love that i don't i hate i
hate
feeling lazy and like nothing's moving
i'm not moving the ball forward a little
bit i totally agree yeah and they say
like what is it like idle time is the
devil's playground yes i yeah i i'm
definitely a victim of like if i don't
have something to do i will find if i
don't have something productive to do
i'll find something destructive to you
yes correct yeah yeah
which is why i quit drinking at the
beginning of this year um
that's awesome thank you so much yeah it
was a big it was a big decision but i'm
34 yeah and it was like two days after
my 34th birthday after day drinking and
i was like i don't even want to like
nothing
at a point now it's like i've never
drank and then felt better
about it yeah like and just in general
nothing good happened when i drank and
then afterwards you're like
anxious and then depressed yes and then
like then like you just feel like it's
just poison it's lit it's literal poison
it is it's actual poison yeah i know i
would i would love to i don't i don't
drink a lot but i would i would love to
get to that point at some point where i
can just i think i only do it socially
now to
to just kind of fit in like do you want
to go get drinks
and then i and then i'm drinking because
i hate drinking
it's i mean i i took all of last year
off like it was just kind of one of
those things of like oh i just i just
want to see what happens if i don't
drink yeah and then in january of this
year start drinking again
and then i was just like this is like i
would just be sitting in my office
thinking about drinking
like it just
like it was just like yeah
at 34 i was like i mean what do you want
to do it's like what do you want to do
in your life is like is it being
hammered and what not so it's like yeah
the one caveat i create is it's like
nick like i went to ireland for a
honeymoon when i got married so it's
like when whenever we go back to ireland
i'll drink a guinness but like otherwise
i'm
done that's awesome no
it's it's exciting it's it's one less
thing to worry about and it saves money
too yeah so much money
money on drinks and then my thing is
money on food
after you've been drinking yeah
i'm like yeah always
of course yeah that's now sugar is my
next uh battle to conquer that's a hard
one sugar's the devil yeah i'm working
on it yeah you might not conquer that
one i'm here for it
oh but thank you so much for doing this
catherine i love it now this became a
therapy session i was like my sobriety
and now i'm trying to quit sugar but
listen i mean you're gonna get how much
sugars and um alcohol that you've been
drinking yeah think about how much
you've already cut out yeah for sure
see appreciate that yeah well where uh
please promote what um what you got
going on where can people keep up with
the one and only katherine blandford uh
well i know i really sold my album well
how much i love it i oh yeah i hate this
go buy it yeah
i i do love it now i look at it is like
okay this is where i was at this point
it's a time capsule it's a time capsule
for sure and now it's a um
to me it's a um
what's what is the word it's like a
blinking reminder to me it's like okay
this is this is what is out there
representing you if you want something
else out there
start working on it
um so i'm like all right i want to put
something else out there to have in
front of that in a year um but i do i
still enjoy it i like the jokes i'm
still working i still do some of those
jokes on the album it is fun i think
it's i'm i'm still proud of it um so
it's called salt daddy uh it's on itunes
and amazon there's some do you know
about that weird legal battle going on
right now with spotify
spotify pandora siriusxm
oh i didn't know there was one on sirius
sirius is paying us
are they not
um you can opt out so i don't i don't
know i don't know the specifics but
there's because it's all about the
composer fees right is that what they're
i think and like it's like writer it's
like musicians get a writing credit and
like a composer credit and like comics
aren't getting a writing credit we're
not getting paid for being a writer of
our content yeah like that siriusxm is
i think there's
labels so
people are involved i'm getting i get
paid from seriously you do yeah that's
awesome for my album okay so i'm
assuming i don't know if maybe i should
be getting paid more though maybe that's
the battle well i've if i've heard you
could opt out of waiting for the
composer fee or whatever to the
the the legal battle to be settled if
you're like okay i don't care you kind
of just wave it off and then you're
being paid
i'm gonna go that route um but that's
kind of that's why the stuff's not on
spotify or pandora any of that right now
uh whatever it doesn't i mean it's it
i'm just i'm still a small fish so i'm
not that worried about it did you did
you release it with a label you're
no i jason riggs i think his his like
company is official titled the comedies
oh does he do stuff atlanta comedy
theater yeah okay he's doing all that
and getting you on serious and all that
yes okay yeah cool yeah that um and then
my socials are at it's catherine
blanford
and uh
podcast cheatis podcast
and
yeah i mean hopefully we'll have a fun
little horse girl web series happening
soon
awesome well the the final thing i asked
comics to do here could you look in the
camera say your name and why people
should listen to hot breath
um
my name is catherine blanford and listen
to hot breath because
uh
it's
it's this is a podcast where people stop
being polite and start getting real and
that's
that's an original uh
slogan right there for sure
awesome thank you so much catherine
blanford yeah thank you appreciate it
awesome
sorry mister uh look at he's taking
photos
oh my gosh no no he's so chill when i do
my broadcast and then
you